foreign
[Music]
nothing is lacking the whole world
belongs to you
rest and be kind you don't have to prove
anything
[Music]
ever goes away until it has taught us
what we need to know
[Music]
the mind of the beginner is empty free
of the habits of the expert ready to
accept to doubt and open to all
possibilities
foreign wherever you are it's the place
you need to be
[Music]
treat every moment as your last
is not preparation for something else
learn to be comfortable in adversity but
most importantly learn to be comfortable
when you're bored
there are only two ways to live your
life one is as if nothing is a miracle
the other is as if everything is a
miracle
[Music]
if you know the enemy and yourself you
need not fear the result of a hundred
battles
spec life Revere life there is nothing
more holy than life nothing more Divine
than life
[Music]
our sorrows and wounds are healed only
when we touch them with compassion
the good life can be as simple as just
paying attention
nature is full of chaos and conflict
don't resist these things invite them
love is the gift of one's innermost soul
to another so both can be whole
the words of the Buddha offer this truth
hatred never ceases by hatred but by
love alone is healed
just as the mother would protect her
only child with her life even so let us
cultivate a boundless love towards all
beings
remember that the best relationship is
one in which your love for each other
exceeds your need for each other
[Music]
friendship is the purest love it is the
highest form of love where nothing is
asked for no condition where one simply
enjoys giving
hatred does not cease by hatred but only
by love
[Music]
is of all passions the strongest for the
tax simultaneously the head the heart
and the senses
if a warrior is not unattached to life
and death he will be of no use
whatsoever
[Music]
peace of mind is that mental condition
in which you have accepted the worst
the true Miracle is not walking on water
or Walking on Air
but simply walking on the Earth
roads were made for Journeys not
destinations
foreign
deeply lived always expands into truths
Beyond itself
when you accept what is every moment is
the best moment
that is enlightenment
not everything happens for a reason
nature is not rational just make peace
with whatever happens
the way to Free Yourself of pain and
suffering is to accept it
foreign
nor wind nor birth nor death can erase
our Good Deeds
the world is afflicted by death and
Decay but the wise do not grieve having
realized the nature of the world
We All Die the goal isn't to live
forever
the goal is to create something that
will
The Man Without word courage dares to
die
the man with inward courage dares to
live
I don't want to die without any scars
the search for happiness is one of the
chief sources of unhappiness
do not dwell in the past do not dream of
the future
concentrate the mind on the present
[Music]
do not let the behavior of others
destroy your inner peace
foreign
if you want happiness for a year inherit
a fortune
if you want happiness for a lifetime
help someone else
there is no need for temples no need for
complicated philosophy our own brain our
own heart is our Temple the philosophy
is kindness
thousands of candles can be lit from a
single candle and the life of the candle
will not be shortened
happiness never decreases by being
shared
kind whenever possible
it is always possible
man suffers only because he takes
seriously what the gods made for fun
life is a journey time is a river the
door is a jar
walk as if you were kissing the Earth
with your feet
it is the power of the mind to be
unconquerable
only the hand that erases can write the
true thing
life is a balance of holding on and
letting go
the place to improve the world is first
in one's own heart and head and hands
foreign
is an effort to become alert and awake
to understand everything is to forgive
everything
[Music]
Zen is not an art it's not a religion
it's a realization
not thinking about anything is Zen once
you know this walking sitting or lying
down everything you do is then
[Music]
the world is its own Magic
those who seek the easy way do not seek
the true way
[Music]
the purpose of Our Lives is to be happy
[Music]
think with your whole body
the menu is not the meal
not engaging in ignorance is wisdom
not creating delusions is enlightenment
let go or be dragged
[Music]
a heartful of laughter is richer than a
Palace full of sadness
[Music]
all things are difficult before they are
easy
foreign
don't speak if it doesn't improve on
silence
[Music]
don't try to steer the river
don't be afraid to just sit and watch
every experience is a lesson every loss
is a gain
Enlightenment is intimacy with all
things
if you've made a mistake it's better
just to laugh at it
it's better to be a person for a day
than to be a shadow for a thousand days
in the highest level a man has the look
of knowing nothing
live calmly the time will come when the
flowers bloom by themselves
man stands in his own shadow and wonders
why it is dark
the first and best Victory is to conquer
self
the more you know the less you need
the Journey of a Thousand Miles begins
with a single step
to seek is to suffer to seek nothing is
bliss
to receive everything one must open
one's hands and give
unhappiness enters through a door that
has been left open
what was never lost can never be found
[Music]
when the student is ready the teacher
will appear
one one first seeks the truth one
separates oneself from it
wise men don't judge they seek to
understand
[Music]
your home is where your thoughts find
peace
even the happiness of a fool is a stupid
kind of happiness
never test the depth of the water with
both feet
if you chase two rabbits you catch none
foreign
s
little people are overwhelmed by
emotions
Zen people are calm and detached
in the midst of chaos there is
opportunity
have the Fearless attitude of a hero and
the loving heart of a child
foreign those who are awake live in a
state of constant amazement
life is like stepping onto a boat which
is about to sail out to sea and seek
be master of Mind rather than Mastered
by mind
the trouble is you think you have time
foreign
to a mind that is still the whole
universe surrenders
we shape clay into a pot but it is the
emptiness inside that holds whatever we
want
love is the absence of judgment
if you miss the present moment you miss
your appointment with life
that is serious
my experience is that the teachers we
need most are the people we're living
with right now
[Music]
awareness is the greatest agent for
change
[Music]
when you do something you should burn
yourself up completely
like a good bonfire leaving no trace of
yourself
[Music]
nothing ever exists entirely alone
everything is in relation to everything
else
when the mind is perfectly clear what is
present is what we want
our Prime purpose in life is to help
others
if you can't help them at least don't
hurt them
[Music]
true Miracle is not walking on water or
Walking on Air
but simply walking on the Earth
[Music]
nature does not hurry yet everything is
accomplished
[Music]
as a Bee Gathering nectar does not harm
or disturb the color and fragrance of a
flower so do the wise move through the
world
resistance to an unpleasant situation is
the root of suffering
sex between two people who love each
other is moral whether they are married
or not
we do not exist for the sake of
something else we exist for the sake of
ourselves
to be beautiful means to be yourself
you don't need to be accepted by others
you need to accept yourself
do not follow the ideas of others learn
to listen to the voice within yourself
happiness lies even in little tiny
butterflies
you just have to open up your eyes and
see where Beauty flies to beautify your
world